có mặt tại hiện chương, phối hợp cơ nơi bị luyên quan khám nghiệp hiện chương.
Đồng thời bảo cao. Để sức bà giám đốc công an tình xác lập truyền án,
vui động nhiều cám buộc, chính sĩ giả kinh nghiệm và cuộc đuôi trà,
chuyến sét cùng sự phối hợp của cuộc kẻng xác hiện sự mục cơ mà.
Giang xác ngày May 3, năm 2019, luật lượng phản đã bắt giữ được tự đặc lần chốn và tuổi giữ các tăng bật kẻa.
Qua đuôi trình khai thác, đuôi thử thay nhận, gió có một thử tình bạc đi này sinh ý định rất hại nạn nhân.
Qua mì bú dự, ngày May 2, 2020, hại đu khiến sê một tốt tuy nhà mang theo khẩu xuống,
mô chí mạo sử dễ nhà của nạn nhân về án.
Sư đó, hại về nhà ở phương bà dị cơ sấu tăng bật.
Hại có hai tình án về tụi, mắt sử người trải pháp lực và tăng chữ trẻ phép chức mặt ý,
hẹn bán trình án đặc tập trung mở giọt đuôi trẻ, làm gió, cùng của sơ để sử dễ hại và các đuôi linh quan,
điều có theo quy định của pháp lực.